we have major major news today that will
severely affect the future of the MCU
what's up everyone it's Warren and today
we have just found out that the deal
between Sony and Marvel is no more and
spider-man will no longer be in the MCU
moving forward I don't feel so good
you're right I don't know I don't know
what's happening now this is obviously
really really upsetting news to many of
the spider-man fans out there especially
considering how much everybody loved Tom
Holland as spider-man in Captain America
Civil War
Avengers infinity war Avengers in games
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home according to a report from
deadline.com after the massive success
that spider-man far from home had Disney
and Sony re-entered negotiations for the
spider-man in the MCU contract the
original contract that Marvel and Disney
had for spider-man in the MCU was for
six films Captain America Civil War
spider-man Home Coming Avengers infinity
war Avengers in game and then of course
spider-man far from home with one
remaining film left then we heard
reports that Marvel and Sony re-entered
negotiations to have more spider-man
films in the MCU with Tom Holland
according to the report from deadlines
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
will no longer produce any further
spider-man films because of an inability
by Disney and Sony Pictures to reach new
terms that would have given the former a
co-financing stake going forward this
mostly comes down to money
Disney asked that future spider-man
films be a 50/50 Co financing
arrangement between the studios and
there were discussions that this might
extend to other films in the spider-man
universe and Sony reportedly turned down
that offer Sony doesn't want to share
its biggest franchise sources say that
Sony proposed keeping the arrangement
going under the current terms where
Marvel receives in the range of a five
percent of the first dollar gross in
which according to this report Disney
declined so essentially what we have
here is that Sony saw the massive
success that spider-man far from home
had and decided they want to keep
spider-man all to themselves but Marvel
is really what made spider-man now of
course spider-man has and always will be
a beloved character of Marvel despite
who owns him spider-man far from home
was the very first spider-man film to
gross over 1 billion dollars and this is
no doubtedly due to the massive success
of all the other MCU films that he was
in especially Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in game which is now officially
the biggest movie of all time if you
take away Avengers end game and
spider-man's involvement in Avengers in
game spider-man far from home doesn't
make over a billion dollars
again people love spider-man he's a
great character but without spider-man
in the MCU spider-man just under Sony
does not do as well so as of right now
unfortunately as the report stands
spider-man will no longer appear in the
MCU as of right now films will continue
to be made with Tom Hollands but Marvel
will have no oversight of the films
however I am hearing from a couple of
sources that the deal isn't officially
over yet and there could be some hope so
if I hear any news whatsoever about the
sony disney deal i'll be sure to do a
video on it and let you all know what's
happening I have no doubt that everybody
is pretty ticked off about this so go
ahead and let it all out in the comments
down below also if you'd like a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 be sure to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below if your favorite
superhero or villain also don't forget
to follow me on Twitter and Instagram
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof